you might still be in shock following
the ending of Avengers infinity war but
hope is on the way in the form of
Captain Marvel it's worth wondering how
any new superhero can be back Thanos
after the mad Titan took down just about
every other Avenger we've combed through
decades of comics and months of
interviews to find out just how powerful
Captain Marvel really is
Farmar energy absorption powers to her
intergalactic political prowess here are
the ways that Captain Marvel could win
the war against Thanos
in adventures for marvelous powers in
the comics Captain Marvel is easily one
of the heaviest hitters in the Marvel
Universe
during infinity one of the fan eccentric
storylines that served as inspiration
for Avengers infinity war Carol Danvers
is part of the strike team of Avengers
that attacked Stannis and his Black
Order on earth that team includes Hulk
Thor and Hyperion who is basically
marvel's equivalent to Superman that's a
powerful group and Captain Marvel is as
strong as any of them Carol Danvers aka
my favorite new Avenger beyond her
powers of super-strength flights and
energy blasts she also has the ability
to absorb various forms of energy like
Chumbawamba Captain Marvel gets knocked
down but gets back up again Thanos might
be strong but this will be the first
time on screen he'll be fighting someone
who gets stronger the more power he
throws in her binary one of Carol
Danvers key attributes is her status as
a cosmic hero no matter what team she's
a part of her adventures very often take
her to space in uncanny x-men number 163
Carol and the x-men were kidnapped by an
alien race known as the brew who
performed experiments on her their
genetic meddling unlocked a new level of
power for Danvers giving her a new
identity binary and a physical
connection with the connective tissue of
the universe Carol eventually burned out
her new powers after restoring a dying
Sun to full health and return to her
previous power levels although when she
overloads her absorption powers she's
still able to tap into binary form
temporarily vanos has no idea what he's
in for
cinematic Smackdown of course the powers
we previously mentioned are all from the
comics even if she's powerful in the
comics she can't possibly be more
powerful than Anne s guardian God or the
sorcerer supreme in the movie
right wrong according to none other than
Marvel Studios chief Kevin Feige himself
Carol Danvers is more formidable than
anyone else we've seen in the MCU thus
far and a talk with vulture buggy said
with Captain Marvel she is as powerful a
character as we've ever put in a movie
her powers are off the charts and when
she's introduced she will be by far the
strongest character we've ever had
there's a very good chance that the
cinematic Carol Danvers can take down
vanos in a straight-up fight even
without the help of the other Avengers
adapting Infinity Gauntlet infinity
served as a major inspiration for some
scenes in infinity war like the Wakanda
invasion and Thanos is Black Order
helping him fight Earth's Mightiest
Heroes but it wasn't the biggest
influence on the film's plot that honor
goes to infinity gauntlet a miniseries
that features Thanos assembling the
Infinity Gauntlet destroying half the
universe in a single snap capturing and
torturing his daughter nebula and
fighting various adventures with the
power of his cosmically powerful
gauntlet sound familiar
in Infinity Gauntlet the remaining
heroes who fight Thanos are led by a
being with cosmic awareness named Adam
warlock while Adam warlock is due to
appear in guardians of the galaxy 3 it's
been confirmed that we won't see him in
Avengers 4 so it's much more likely that
directors Joe and Anthony Russo will sub
in Captain Marvel man with a plan the
reason that we're even talking about
Captain Marvel's involvement in the
upcoming Avengers flick is due to Nick
Fury dialing her up on a space pager at
the end of Avengers infinity war fury
has faked his death at least once on
screen and the man's got a plan for
everything
it's not unlikely that he's anticipated
in an event on this scale and worked out
a plan with Danvers before she left for
space while fury might be gone in
Avengers for the massive network of
shield operatives should still be around
well half of them anyway it makes sense
that they would turn to the woman that's
most experienced to take advantage of it
military expertise aside from her powers
there's another aspect to Captain Marvel
that might come into play for Avengers
for her military experience and role as
a leader she was an executive director
of shield in the Ultimate Universe and
even in the regular Marvel Universe she
was a colonel in the Air Force not to
mention the many times she's led a team
of heroes for
planetary defense or as the head of
alpha flights while her superpowers in
fighting prowess are arguably the
flashiest aspects of the character it
just might be her military leadership
that helps her rally the Avengers to
finally stop vows thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]